hey everyone i'm alan and welcome to my
channel where today
i am very excited because a new black
myth wukong trailer dropped i've watched
every single one of these as reactions
uh i think this game looks so awesome um
obviously i'm a few days late this has
come out
a fair bit ago now but i just haven't
had time to catch up so doing it right
now this is the official unreal engine 5
gameplay trailer we've had a bunch of
teasers previously so i don't want to
spoil anything for myself but hoping
this is kind of a more substantial
trailer more of an indication of what
the game currently looks like rather
than kind of the the demos we've been
seeing previously but i think this game
is super cool love the concept huge fan
of the story so let's just do it shall
we we're watching this one on ign let's
go
in game there you go
it is a work in progress of course
but some of the stuff previously
i don't know that it was all a game
monkey
manchester
foreign
you're kidding me
oh my god
that animation
like enslaved other games that have
focused on this
this story
but i feel like it coming from a chinese
studio is especially exciting
ooh
creepy
that's very sakura
cool
because like some of their other
trailers were one of them was for the
year of the ox another one was um
for hiring purposes
oh my god it's hard to believe this game
is real
damn look at all these particles bro
the animation's
very good
like the eyes and everything
all right the snow there was definitely
i feel like red dead redemption 2 really
set a standard for snow
snow is certainly not as smooth
it's working progress obviously and also
it doesn't really matter
whether one individual footsteps
this looks insane
oh my god
how they gonna make running look that
satisfying you know
is that a parry bar
oh i might be covering it for you guys
unfortunately
on the the bottom left i think
oh that was cool
the bottom right is that ui for a like
what weapon type or stance type
oh they just activated something i need
to watch this through multiple times
that's so sick
i just i don't okay so the the bottom
right was leading up to that i think and
you bloody wasted it
it looks like the hitbox is very
forgiving
which i don't feel like it always is in
the souls games like i feel like i'd be
getting chewed up
oh that looks so cool
damn
what's going on here
[Music]
oh my hello
all right
[Music]
oh
i also like i don't remember the other
trailers because i i watch them you know
the day they come out and then not again
and i feel like
i don't remember how much things have
changed i kind of want to go back and
watch the old ones as well
but this does say it's an official
trailer but maybe igen's lying to me oh
cool
holy [ __ ] that looks good
what
[Music]
the physics of the thing the movement
oh my god
i don't know how long my face was just
stuck like that but
i caught myself
[ __ ] hell
the like individual strands moving
independently
and it's not clipping on itself
seemingly damn
also just very different looking from
the previous i don't know boss fight i
would think that we saw i love their
including gameplay whether
the player is failing
the hits actually do a lot of damage
the bar is going down
i'm gonna move my webcam real quick
so you guys can see the other parts of
the ui there
this dragon is cool as hell
the sound design also sounds really good
just got belly slapped right in the face
i want to play this so bad i feel like i
watch a lot of trailers for games and
i'm like oh interesting i'm gonna enjoy
this
but the wukong trailers that we've seen
because they are really just
i'm right
just like straight gameplay like this
just makes me want to it makes me
frustrated that i can't play this right
now
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
don't want to get electrocuted under
that mate that'd be a bad time
foreign
it's all so fluid
[Music]
that's very cool i feel like i remember
that from
[Music]
this has got to be an expensive video
game
who is funding them
you don't understand how expensive four
legs are in video games
[Music]
damn
it makes me wonder is like is the open
world kind of limited because
the bosses have such
detail like what
how you know
what is it missing in order to be able
to do that
[Applause]
by
[Music]
looks amazing it looks amazing um i'm i
do want to rewatch it like properly
analyze everything i'm seeing here
looks like this still has a little bit
left
[Music]
obviously you're getting my fresh
reactions which are
amazed
here's my take
all the it's all the particles that get
me oh those aren't even like
just
those like bats
[Music]
that text wasn't the finest work
okay there you go
damn man
amazing very very very cool
um
is there anything else
no i wanted to see
what other info they have here
so unreal five gameplay trailer that
means it probably is just an actual
gameplay trailer
from chinese developer game science this
is our first look at black with mooco
blackmail wukong running on unreal
legend five at 4k
60 frames a second will also support
nvidia's ray tracing and dlss as well as
adobe atlas
hell yeah
man that looks good that's my hot take
it looks very good i do want to watch it
again and look into it further because
yeah we have seen a bunch of stuff about
this game and um
or a bunch of these kind of videos
without
them necessarily being accurate like one
of them was a recruiting tool i also
want to know who's funding it because
this looks like an expensive video game
very very impressed